aquí tenemos una conformación de silla
de metil ciclohexano este es el carbono
uno hay un grupo metilo que está axial
arriba en el carbono 1 también hay un
hidrógeno este hidrógeno es verde para
diferenciarlo de los otros hidrógenos y
este hidrógeno está ecuatorial abajo en
el carbono 1 esta conformación de sí ya
está en equilibrio con otra conformación
de silla y podemos llegar a la otra
conformación de silla por medio de una
inversión del anillo si muevo este
carbono hacia arriba y jalo este carbono
hacia abajo y giramos un poco la
molécula podemos ver la otra
conformación de silla de metil
ciclohexano ahora cuando vemos el
carbono 1 podemos ver que ocurrió un
cambio en el carbono 1 el grupo metilo
está ahora ecuatorial observa que sigue
estando arriba con respecto al plano del
anillo pero ahora está ecuatorial y el
hidrógeno ahora está axial sigue estando
abajo pero ahora es axial esto es lo que
sucede en una inversión del anillo
ya que hemos visto el vídeo de el metil
ciclohexano experimentando una inversión
del anillo
ahora vamos a dibujar las dos con
formaciones de silla para dibujar la
conformación de silla de la izquierda
comienzo con dos líneas paralelas
desfasadas entre sí y luego dibujo una
línea punteada aquí que toca el punto
superior de la línea de arriba y una
línea punteada que toque el punto
inferior de la línea de abajo después
trazamos una línea desde aquí hasta la
línea punteada inferior y luego desde
aquí hasta la línea punteada superior y
finalmente tenemos otro conjunto de
líneas paralelas para darnos un total de
tres conjuntos de líneas paralelas
empezamos en el carbono 1 y comenzamos
con un enlace axial arriba y luego en el
carbono 2 sería axial abajo el carbono 3
axial arriba en el carbono 4 axial abajo
en el 5 va arriba y en el 6 va hacia
abajo
a continuación ponemos los enlaces
ecuatoriales así que en el carbono 1
empezamos con ecuatorial abajo en el
carbono 2 es ecuatorial arriba en el
carbono 3 sería hacia abajo en el
carbono 4 sería hacia arriba en el
quinto carbono va hacia abajo y en el
carbono 6 sería hacia arriba muy bien
esta conformación de silla está en
equilibrio con la otra conformación de
silla así que vamos a dibujar la otra
conformación de silla y luego regresamos
para colocar los diferentes grupos para
dibujar la otra conformación de silla
utilizamos el mismo método dibujamos dos
líneas paralelas que están desfasadas
entre sí así que esas son mis dos líneas
paralelas y después dibujamos una línea
punteada que intersecta la parte de
arriba de la línea superior
y luego trazamos otra línea punteada que
intersecta la parte de abajo de la línea
inferior
ahora dibujamos otro conjunto de líneas
paralelas así que dibujamos esta y para
la otra piensa en trazar una línea
paralela a esta última por ultimo
conectamos estos puntos de esta forma y
estas líneas deben ser paralelas también
ahora este es el carbono 1 y hacemos lo
contrario de lo que hicimos antes
empezamos con axial abajo este es axial
abajo
este es el carbono 2 y va a axial arriba
en el carbono 3 está axial abajo en el
carbono 4 va axial arriba el carbono 5
va axial abajo y por último en el
carbono 6 va axial arriba regresamos al
carbono 1 para colocar los enlaces
ecuatoriales ahora debido a que
empezamos con axial abajo en este
carbono entonces este en la selva
ecuatorial arriba luego en el carbono 2
va ecuatorial abajo en el carbono 3 es
ecuatorial arriba en el carbono 4 va
ecuatorial abajo en el carbono 5 está
ecuatorial arriba y por último en el
carbono 6 va ecuatorial abajo ahora
vamos a colocar a nuestros grupos
volvamos al diagrama de la izquierda
este es el carbono 1 tenemos un grupo
metilo axial arriba por lo tanto aquí
abajo ponemos un ch3 axial arriba en el
carbono 1
y luego tenemos este hidrógeno verde
aquí que está ecuatorial abajo así que
dibujamos este hidrógeno ecuatorial
abajo lo circular en verde para
distinguirlo mejor podría dibujar los
otros hidrógenos pero voy a dejar así
esta conformación de silla dibujar todos
estos enlaces es una buena forma de
practicar y también podríamos colocar
todos los hidrógenos pero no nos
enfocaremos en eso por ahora nuestro
objetivo es mostrar la inversión del
anillo así que en el carbono 1 este es
el carbono 1 este carbono de aquí es
este carbono de aquí después de la
inversión del anillo y observen lo que
le sucedió a nuestro grupo metilo
comenzó a estando axial arriba y este
grupo metilo sigue estando arriba pero
observa que ahora es ecuatorial por lo
que vamos a colocar ecuatorial al grupo
metilo en el carbono 1 recuerda que este
es el carbono 1 y luego nuestro
hidrógeno
el verde aún está abajo con respecto al
plano del anillo pero ahora está axial
este es nuestro hidrógeno verde lo voy a
circular en color verde ahora está axial
abajo en relación con el plano así que
lo importante de una inversión del
anillo es que cualquier grupo que se
encuentre axial pasa a ser ecuatorial y
cualquier grupo que esté ecuatorial se
vuelve axial eso es lo que cambia sin
embargo lo que no cambia es si un grupo
se encuentra arriba o abajo con respecto
al plano del anillo voy a señalarlo aquí
el grupo metilo permanece arriba aquí se
encuentra axial arriba y de este lado
sigue estando arriba con relación al
plano pero ahora está ecuatorial lo que
estaba abajo era nuestro hidrógeno aquí
se encuentra ecuatorial abajo el
hidrógeno se mantiene hacia abajo con
respecto al plano del anillo pero se
vuelve axial así que necesitas practicar
dibujando todo esto ahora vamos a pensar
en cuál es la conformación más estable
así que tenemos dos con formaciones de
silla y una es más estable que la otra
veamos esta fotografía de aquí y echemos
un vistazo a la interacción de este
grupo metilo con estos otros
los axiales pensemos en este hidrógeno
de aquí y en este hidrógeno de aquí
atrás este grupo metilo ocupa mucho
espacio y se encuentra bastante cerca de
estos hidrógenos nos encontramos con un
impedimento estético importante al
colocar al grupo metilo en la posición
axial sin embargo en esta conformación
de la derecha tenemos este grupo metilo
saliendo hacia el lado en una posición
ecuatorial ahora este grupo metilo no
interfiere con ninguno de los hidrógenos
axiales aquí abajo tenemos un hidrógeno
que podría tener cierta interacción con
estos otros hidrógenos pero no es para
nada tan grave como lo que tendríamos de
poner al grupo metilo en esta posición
así que lo que buscamos al tener un
sustituye ente relativamente voluminoso
es ponerlo en la posición ecuatorial y
esa va a ser la conformación más estable
y resulta que en el equilibrio a
temperatura ambiente esta conformación
de silla de la derecha es
aproximadamente el 95% más frecuente que
todas las conformaciones de silla del
ciclo hexano y la de la izquierda
presenta una frecuencia de alrededor del
5% por lo tanto este es un efecto muy
importante el impedimento estético que
desestabiliza esta conformación es
conocido como interacción de axial 13
este es el carbono 1 y aquí tenemos un
sustituye ente axial este es el carbono
2 y este es el carbono 3 en el carbono 3
tenemos otro sustituye ente axial y
estos dos pueden interferir entre sí y
es por eso que llamamos a esto una
interacción de axial 13 y axial es decir
tenemos dos sustituye entes que son
axiales así que interacción
y axial
ocurre lo mismo con este hidrógeno de
aquí atrás y este impedimento estético
desestabiliza esta conformación el
efecto es aún más pronunciado cuando se
tiene un grupo más grande que está
interfiriendo con estos hidrógenos
axiales por ejemplo si cambiamos nuestro
grupo metilo por un grupo de butilo voy
a bajar la pantalla para que podamos ver
a un grupo tribu tilo solo dibuje
algunos enlaces aquí aquí está el grupo
termo tilo en el carbono 1 y si pensamos
en la interacción de axial 13 voy a
dibujar algunos hidrógenos aquí puesto
que tenemos todos estos grupos metilo
aquí esto va a generar aún más
impedimento estético y es por eso que en
el equilibrio entre estas dos
conformación es el 99.99 por ciento del
tiempo esta molécula va a estar en esta
conformación con su súper voluminoso el
grupo de butilo en posición ecuatorial y
hacia el lado lo que disminuye el
impedimento estético